hey guys Pete here this will be my
breakdown of the Dark trilogy trailer
they just released I've seen it with the
name trilogy and the name franchise
trailer whatever you want to call it the
trailer they just put out the third
trailer for season 3 the first half of
it recaps the first two seasons and then
we get about a minute of new footage the
whole thing is great but I'm just gonna
focus on the new stuff in this video
before we get into it this is your
spoiler warning this video will discuss
everything that's happened in dark
through the first two seasons I'll talk
about the things we've seen in all the
season three trailers and promo material
so far a few days ago netflix released a
ton of press photos that I haven't had a
chance to talk about yet they're mostly
from the first two episodes and I'll
discuss them when they add context to
some of the things we see in this
trailer if any of that doesn't sound
like your cup of tea now's your chance
to leave as mentioned the first half of
the trailer shows us how we got to where
we are at the beginning of season 3 the
one thing that stands out at the end is
that we see how alt Martha's journey is
very similar to Eunice's right after we
see Marta save Jonas from the apocalypse
at the end of season 2 the trailer cuts
to the alt world version of the con
walled house we noticed the background
is reversed to help distinguish which
world we're looking at there's a shot of
yonas looking at something in the alt
world it's kind of funny since the thing
that looks different about him is that
his hair is just parted on the other
side next we see Marta talking to Yanis
in the cave I mentioned in one of my
recent videos how this Marta the one
with the shorter hair and dark clothes
is at least slightly older than the one
we see in the yellow raincoat think of
the yonus in the yellow raincoat we meet
at the beginning compared to the one in
darker clothes who has traveled and has
the scar on his neck so these two are in
the cave and there are a couple clearer
photos of them in the promo pics those
are labeled episode 1 and in them we see
Marta travelling my guess is that this
version of Marta has brought yonas to
the alt world at some point before the
apocalypse happens there and in this
scene she's leaving him this means that
he can go meet the one who wears the
raincoat and most likely explains some
things
about time travel to her the next shot
is the burning of Michels suicide note
which looks like recycled footage from
season one that cuts to the trio
watching Adams lair burn there's a
couple of images of this in the press
photos which are labeled episode one as
well if that's correct we won't have to
wait long to see what they're up to as
it burns we hear a voiceover of a
woman's voice saying everything will
fall apart in this world in yours as
she's saying that we see raincoat Marta
riding her bike much like Jonas did at
the beginning of season 1 after that we
see the power plant with three people in
radiation suits standing in front of
where the god particle was I say where
it was because now there's just a
hovering white glowing ball rather than
the black blob the shot is too far away
to say who's standing there but we did
see older Elizabeth and Charlotte
wearing yellow radiation suits in the
last trailer the very next scene looks
like original Charlotte in the 2053 time
line which makes her a good candidate
there's a transition shot of yonas
walking away from the cave we see it's
the alt world because of the red and
white tape instead of blue and white
then we get a scene with Hannah where we
see her wearing the st. Christopher
pendant for the first time most of us
knew this was coming but it still turned
out to be a scene to make you gasp
because we see agon behind her clasping
it on her neck if there was any doubt
these two would start a relationship we
can put those to rest this is the first
of two big revelations from this trailer
there aren't any photos of the 1950s
timeline at all besides the behind the
scenes ones that bbo posted on his
Instagram so this is exciting to see
next we see Adam in the power plant in
the 2050s timeline the black blob is
still there so if we put two and two
together it looks like whatever he's
doing here will result in the change we
saw in it earlier we've seen a few
sequences and previous trailers that
make it look like this is all part of
whatever he has planned there's a
sequence of recycled images of the
notebook Noah
Jung Helga in the operational version of
the chair in some shots of the future
that might be new or
those could be recycled as well after
that there's an interesting shot of the
actor who plays midal Claudia someone is
holding the orb time machine setting it
to travel
Claudia looks somewhat dirty and her
hair is different but I don't know if
you can tell for sure if this is all
Claudia or if she just looks like that
from being in the bunker after the
apocalypse this reminded me of the shot
in the first trailer where we saw
Claudia traveling and now I'm wondering
if this is all Claudia traveling in
front of her prime world version they
look like they could be happening in the
same place so let me know what you think
about this in the comments we know at
some time Claudia travels to the alt
world and there's no reason to believe
that there wouldn't be an altar of her
so we could see them getting together
right here next we see raincoat marta
kiss jonas in front of the cave that
cuts to a couple having sex in the con
walled house based on the paneling on
the walls
you can't tell for sure who this is or
which world but it seems pretty likely
that it's yonas and alt marta in her
world there's a quick shot of older alt
Helga sitting in a chair it's short and
it doesn't look different than when we
saw him in previous trailers then we see
Jonas holding the st. Christopher
pendant briefly possibly in the cave
this mirror is a shot we saw earlier of
Marta holding it from season 2 that cuts
the stranger Jonas in the distant past
timeline with tears in his eyes there
was a wider version of this in the promo
photos where you can see that Marta is
standing in front of him this is where I
think alt Marta goes after she leaves he
Onis in the cave since this all seems to
be from the first episode this is most
likely 1888 or some time not too long
after that and it is probably connected
to the other shot we saw of sick mundos
building the time machine with alt
Martha looking on after that there's
some recycled shots of Nichols
disappearance
showing yonus and Ulrich running through
the woods then there is a quick shot of
lights flickering in the alt-world
school you can see the doors are a
darker color and this is where the press
photo of alt Hannah that's out there is
from the flickering lights shot cuts to
Hannah and aegon back in the
and she doesn't look pleased it's a
quick look and the big takeaway seems to
be that things are going sour between
them then we get the other big reveal
from this trailer we see two people
touching hands across the chessboard we
can tell by the pattern on the
sweatshirt that this is Katerina on the
right and it looks like she will be
reunited with Ulrich based on this shot
we can confirm that he's wearing the
same sweater and you can even see the
chessboard I think it's great that these
two will have a scene together and it'll
be interesting since he's 33 years older
than the last time she saw him Catarina
was pretty well confirmed to have
traveled back to 86 in the prime world
and this shot appears to seal the deal
it also adds fuel to the fire what we
expect to go down between her and her
mother Helene now bears we know she
works here so it looks like they may be
crossing paths not long after this
reunion after that there's another
really interesting shot of a book being
closed on a desk there's a pen beside it
and the clothing seems to be a match for
what we see the trio wearing according
to Reddit the words on the page are from
the play Ariadne that we saw Martha
performance season 1 a book of the play
showed up in the last trailer and there
are a couple of promo photos showing
that she performs to play in the old
world as well
the other interesting thing here is the
illustration at the top of the page we
see a circle that is half blacked out
with the letter A below it this looks
very similar to the illustration in the
book that Elizabeth found in tan houses
shop in that there are two globes on
either side of one in the center there's
a male and a female character blowing on
each of them and there's a theory that
there Adam and Eve the globes refer to
both woman's we know of and they're
connected to a prime world that we're
yet to see I think seeing this has me
thinking about it more and you can't
deny that when Elizabeth looks at the
book the camera lingers in a way that
makes it feel like it's important like
we're supposed to notice it next we have
the shot of alt Marta with the bloody
hand standing at the mouth of the cave
we have no idea whose blood this is but
it does look like this is where the mark
on her cheek comes from it's also
probably where she ditches the rain coat
since it
completely covered with blood here then
we see her wake up from a nightmare like
we've seen the onus and stranger do many
times before she does this twice and it
mirrors the beginning of the trailer
where we see Jonas and stranger both
wake up the first time we see Marta I
think it's the prime version since she
doesn't have bangs the second time it's
definitely the alt world since she's
sleeping in the con walled house and she
has the longer hair like she does when
she's wearing the raincoat after that we
see the alt world gang in front of the
cave from left to right it's the new
character Killian bartosh Magnus
Francisca and Marta we see them turn and
look towards the cave and then their
flashlights start to flicker in one of
the promo pics we see Killian and Marta
holding hands at the school and it looks
like he's our boyfriend in that we can
see a missing poster for Eric Oberndorf
hanging on the wall it looks exactly
like the one in prime world we don't
know any details about that yet but
that's probably why they're searching
around in the woods at night then
there's a shot of marta in the woods
that mirrors the one of the onus after
getting separated from Mikkel there's a
shot of Mikael suicide note in the box
followed by some reverse shots of the
bloody rock the police arriving at the
bridge and then Marta kissing Jonas
again that cuts through the last shot of
the trailer of raincoat Marta turning to
look back in front of the cave this is
where the world looks like a desert
which i think is in the far future
probably 2086 or beyond so it's another
great trailer the two big reveals are
seeing Hannah and Aegon together this
doesn't look like a fling this looks
like they're having a relationship we
have the origin of the st. Christopher
pendant confirmed and that definitely
makes you think about how it ended up on
the beach where yonus and Marta will
find it many years later
this makes the lady in the lake theory
seem even more probable and I've never
really jumped on the bandwagon of Hannah
having another child
I thought they definitely hinted in
season two that these two might hook up
but seeing the way this is presented
here I wouldn't put anything past them
seeing Katarina with Ulrich is fantastic
and there's just so much tragedy when
you think
the fact that she's probably gonna end
up on the wrong end of a rock that's
wielded by her own mother just a tough
situation all the way around there's a
lot to think about here I'll probably
follow this up with another theory video
in a couple of days just like I did with
the last couple of trailers I think I'll
end this one here make sure to tell me
what you think about this trailer about
everything else that's going on what
you're hoping to see how are your
theories shifting are you changing your
mind about what you think this is going
to happen at the end of the series we
only have eight more days to go so make
sure you like this video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel give
me a follow on Twitter or Instagram if
you haven't already and thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon